we're on problem 27 and the question is
which equation best represents the graph
above so before even looking at the
choices let's see what we could figure
out about this graph so where it's
what's its y-intercept if we said that
this is the equation of a line we said Y
is equal to M X plus B where m is the
slope and Y is and B is the y-intercept
it's late I'm getting slightly muddled
so what's the y-intercept well when X is
equal to 0 Y is equal to 0
so this is going to be equal to 0 the
y-intercept is 0 right when X is equal
to 0 Y is equal to 0 so the y-intercept
is 0 so we know that this has a form y
is equal to MX where m is a slope now
let's figure out the slope slope is
equal to change in Y for given change in
X or change in Y over change in X so
when we increase X by 1 how much are we
increase or decrease Y by well then Y
increases by 2 right so we could say
that equals Y increases by 2 by +2 when
X changes by +1 so we get the slope is
equal to 2 so the equation of this line
is y is equal to 2x which is choice B
choice B next problem which point lies
on the line defined by 3x plus 6y is
equal to 2 well the best thing to do is
just probably just substitute these
numbers in for X and Y and see which one
works so here x is 0 Y is 2 so let's see
3 times 0 plus 6 times 2 is equal to 0
plus 12 doesn't equal 2 equals 12 so
it's not equal to this one doesn't work
all right I'm just taking 3 times X plus
6 times y and see what it equals in this
case we have 3 times 0 plus 6 times y
plus 6 times 6 well that's 0 plus 36
that doesn't equal 2 it can't be that
choice this one we have 3 right this 3
times 1 plus 6 times this y 6 times
minus 1/6
so let's see what it is that's three
that's equal to three and then six times
1/6 is one but we have a negative out
there so it's minus one so that is equal
to two so that that works three times
one plus six times negative 1/6 is equal
to two so our answer is C problem 29 let
me see if I need a cut and paste this
one in alright so there yeah I think
it's a good idea let me see
copy and paste it let me copy and paste
it the next several problems we could
just move be streamlined about it okay
they all fit I'm good enough all right
what is the equation of the line that
has slope of four and passes through the
point 3 comma minus 10 so if the slope
is 4 we know that the line so if you
know just rewrite it in slope
y-intercept form again MX plus B they're
telling us that the slope is 4 all right
so we know the equation of the line is y
is equal to 4 X plus the y-intercept and
then we could figure out the y-intercept
by substituting in this point that they
say it goes through so it goes through
the point 3 comma negative 10 so Y is
equal to minus 10y is equal to minus 10
when X is equal to 3 so 4 times X X is
equal to 3 plus B so what is that it's
minus 10 is equal to 12 plus B we could
subtract 12 from both sides of this
equation and we get minus 22 all right
minus 10 minus 12 is minus 22 is equal
to this 12 obviously goes away is equal
to B so the equation of our line is y is
equal to 4x plus B which we just figured
out as minus 22 for X minus 22 that's
choice a problem 30 the data in the
table and the data in the table show the
call
of renting a bicycle by the hour
including a deposit all right
if hours H were graphed on the
horizontal axis let me see if I can I
can draw that so that is on the
horizontal axis I have hours H so this
is H and cost were graphed on the
vertical axis let me draw the vertical
axis so cost is on the vertical axis
what would be the equation of the line
that fits the data okay so they just
want to know cost as a function of hours
so let's see we could we could you know
it's a linear relationship we could
treat this just like any other line so
if we write it as y equals MX plus B I
don't even have to do this so Y is equal
to MX plus B so M or the slope is equal
to change in Y over all right let me
write it differently because we want it
in terms of so we could write C is equal
to the slope times the hours plus B
right instead of X we have hours instead
of Y we have the cost right so what's
the slope slope is equal to change in
the dependent variable change in cost
divided by a change in the independent
variable divided by change in hours so
let's see if I say if when our hours
increased by 3
how much did our did our change in C go
by when you'll go from 2 to 5 so if we
say 5 minus 2 that's how much we changed
in hours right that's Delta H then how
much did we change in cost
well it's 30 minus 15 so it equals 15
over 3 which is equal to 5 so we figured
out the slope slope is equal to 5 now we
just have to figure out the y-intercept
so this equation we could rewrite it as
cost is equal to the slope which is 5
times the hours plus whatever our
y-intercept is and now we just have to
substitute one of the points in to solve
for B just like we did in the previous
video
so let's substitute the point when H is
equal to 2c is equal to 15 so the point
2 comma 15 so when H is equal to 2 C is
equal to 15 C is equal to 15 when H is
equal to 2 and now we can just solve for
B so you get 15 is equal to 10 plus B
subtract 10 from both sides you get B is
equal to 5 so the equation of this line
if cost is equal to 5 times H 5 times h
plus our y-intercept R plus our C
intercept we could say so plus 5 5 h
plus 5 and that is choice C if you try
it out with these points it should all
work ok next problem let me see
I think this cutting and pasting works
out well ok I have time for at least two
more ok let me clear this clear this one
right here let me paste it in ok it says
some ordered pairs for a linear function
of X are given in the table below
ok it's kind of like the last one which
of the following equations was used to
generate the table above well we could
do the same thing we did the last time
we could say ok this is going to have
some relation you know Y is equal to MX
plus B it's going to be a line and this
is the slope y-intercept form and it
tells us the linear function so that's
that Y we can immediately say that's
going to be a line there's no x squared
or anything like that so a good place to
start is just what with the slope so
slope is equal to change in Y over
change in X so let's see when X goes
from 1 to 3 what does y go fir goes from
1 to 7 right so change in X is equal to
3 minus 1 or just 2 right and what's
change in Y 7 minus 1
so that is equal to 6 over oh no sorry
change in X was 3-1 sorry about that 3-1
so it's 6 over 2 alright when X changes
by 2 right that's this to change in X Y
changes by 6 its change in Y so the
slope is 3 so the equation of our line
is going to be Y is equal to 3 X plus
some y-intercept and now we could
substitute some points in let's
substitute this one this one 1 seems
easy so Y is equal to 1 when X is equal
to 1 all right so we get 1 is equal to 3
plus B subtract 3 from both sides of
this equation and we get what might 1
minus 3 is minus 2 is equal to obviously
this disappears 3 minus 3 so B is equal
to minus 2 so the equation of our line
we have a slope of 3 and a y-intercept
of -2 the equation is going to be y is
equal to 3x plus B well B is minus 2 so
minus 2 and that is choice C choice C 32
the equation of line L is 6x plus 5y
equals 3 and the equation of line Q is
5x minus 6y is equal to 0 which of the
statements about the two lines are true
okay let's see they have the same
y-intercept they're parallel they have
the same x-intercept lines L and Q are
perpendicular so well I'll tell you how
you can identify perpendicular lines
they have the negative inverse of each
other slope but I'll I don't know if
that's going to come into play yet I
always find it easier to look at these
lines in in in in kind of the slope
y-intercept form so let's do that so
line L can be 6x plus 5y is equal to 3
so if we were to subtract 6x from both
sides you get 5y is equal to minus 6x
plus 3 and then you divide both sides by
watt 5 and you
y is equal to minus 6/5 X plus
three-fifths so this is line L right
here I'll do line I'll do line Q in a
different color so Q is 5x minus 6y is
equal to zero let's subtract 5x from
both sides you get minus 6y is equal to
minus 5x if you divide both sides by
negative 6 you get Y is equal to minus 5
divided by negative 6 it's 5 6x so look
at well actually it looks like D comes
into play because the slope of this one
is minus 6/5 that's the slope of line el
the slope of line Q is the inverse of
that made negative and that's just at
this point it's a good thing to memorize
I haven't proven it to you yet but when
you want a if you want a line that has a
slope perpendicular to this one or line
who that is perpendicular to this one
will have a negative inverse slope so
the inverse of this is minus 5/6 and the
negative inverse is plus 5/6 so this is
the negative inverse of that so these
lines are actually perpendicular so that
is d see in the next video